- Welcome back to Kevin
Hart's the Kelly Clarkson show
A Tribute to Rad Dads.
Kevin Hart is co-hosting and
co-producing today. Give it up!
Are you happy with your
wine and your chip combo or?
- I'm not gonna lie to
you this is good wine
but I feel like we can do
better. If this was my show.
- Yes, it is your show today.
So let's do better,
- Do you have better?
- [Kelly] Do you want
better chips as well.
- This is good but this isn't
what I would technically have
if we were at like an event
for me, there's a better chip.
There's a better wine.
- Yeah
I feel like my suit is
deserving of a better wine.
Hello! Come on now!
(drums)
- All right can you
bring that out, Justin?
Can you bring the better one
and the better chips out?
You feel like? Oh
- Please.
- Oh, okay.
Okay, we have a platter.
- Why didn't you bring
this up the first time?
See thank you. This is
what I'm talking about Now we talking
- Take this crap out of here.
- Yeah, now we talking
- Okay
- If I ask for a chip.
Give me a chip one that I can get some dip
and maybe move my hip.
- I can go to him first.
(drum and piano riff)
Now you got first to him
first cause it's your show.
- Thank you, thank you.
- See he knew.
- You get it. You're starting to get it.
- Yeah. I didn't help him at all.
- Now he's starting to get
it this is really good.
- Okay. Let's taste this one.
Is the lighting Okay, As well?
Are you good? Are you vibing?
- I am, but I'm no
longer feeling electric.
I feel like now we're
in the mode of comfort.
So give me something else.
Let me feel a little comfortable guys.
Can you hit me with something else?
- Okay.
- Give me a little light change.
Yeah. Now I'm in the house.
- [Kelly] I'm feeling warm.
- Yes!
- This is so nice
- [Narrator] Yes, you
guys are in fact drinking,
Duck Horn, The Discussion.
This wine has notes of Blackberry.
And when it opens, you'll
notice espresso and vanilla.
- I got the espresso vanilla too. Did you?
- I taste it now. After
he said it, I tasted it.
Which means that next
time before I taste it
tell me so I know what I'm looking for.
- Note, that's a note.
- Yes, I'm sorry.
- No Well you have a comment
card. We should have a box.
So wait, your new book is
out. Okay. This is awesome.
It's called Marcus Makes a Movie.
So what's your message
for kids in this book.
Why'd you want to do this?
- First of all, when
you say that title Kelly
you're supposed to punch that title.
- Marcus Makes a movie!
- There you go, but you
don't have the drums. I do.
- Damn Lester!
- It's called Marcus Makes a Movie!
(drums)
- Dammit
I think my drummer just quit
and wants to work for you now.
- By the way our timing is impeccable.
Marcus Makes a Movie.
This is a book that I decided to write to
inspire the youth the generation today.
I feel like the word no is
powerful. Is discouraging.
And sometimes you do need, a little
push and understanding
that no, is not forever.
It's a moment, and this
is the book of a guy
a young kid that heard the word no
and didn't want to accept it.
And he wanted to create his opportunity
which is what life is about.
It's about creating and
making opportunities
making the best of them and
having the ambition to drive,
to do it, stay with it
ultimately succeed for whatever
that level of success is.
In this case, it was about
making his dream movie
that he was told he couldn't
do because he had no money.
He had no cameras
and he found a way to do it
without having those assets.
But by just having the help
of some friends, ambition
and ultimately a dream
and a dream comes true
but it's a nice journey.
It's a good journey.
And I want kids to understand
that's what life is.
Life is a journey, a journey
worth living and embracing.
You know why? Because at the end of it
we all get to look back at
our story and Marcus's story,
It's amazing. Wow. Did I sum that up?
Hit me with it.
Yes!
- That was awesome I feel
inspired, first of all right now!
- I'm crushing this. I'm crushing this
- What was your experience
like? I don't know.
Did you ever, have we ever told no
about something and then you feel
like you push through
anyway that you could do it.
Somebody told you you can't
do something and you did.
- Well Kelly, first and
foremost, let me take the time to
echo what you just said
- Okay
- because Kelly, that
was a great question.
- Okay I feel
- I was told no.
We all were told no's
at some point in time,
Kelly but here's the thing.
My no's ultimately became my
drive and want toward my yes.
Right. I was told that I wasn't funny.
I was told that I wasn't going to make it.
- What Jackass told you that?
- Several!
I was told that my movies
would never show overseas
and do business overseas.
I was told the likelihood
of me being a movie star
was not likely, I was told everything.
- Wow
- That is the complete
opposite of what I now am.
And here's the thing.
When I was told that I didn't
get angry, I didn't get mad.
I just use it as personal fire
for myself because I believe
in a certain thing that I felt I had.
- You are Marcus.
- I am Marcus. Marcus comes from me.
It comes from my life, and
my story, we just did it
in a way to where kids
will be able to identify
with it as well.
- Yeah
- The word no, once again, it's temporary.
It's not forever, man.
And that's the biggest thing that I
want this young generation
to truly understand.
- I love that, dream big. Do
you want to read the toss?
Cause it's your show today.
- I can read the toss guys. Listen to me.
Marcus Makes a Movie is available now
wherever you buy books I repeat,
- Marcus Makes a Movie is available now,
wherever you buy books,
hit me with it one time
Yeah! If that was a book
you would have bought it.